you're an extreme proponent of bitcoin
say something nice about dogecoin oh i
think that dogecoin community is
obviously super engaged and frankly i
think that uh one of the things around
dogecoin that ends up being uh
everyone likes to dismiss it but like
memes run the world right the meme is
the message and there may not be very
much like much better memes i still
think bitcoin's a stronger meme
obviously and i think that's why it
continues to kind of propagate but i
think that dogecoin is an incredibly
strong meme and you can argue whether
it's a good meme a badminton whatever
but like
there's a ton of people who hold it and
that is why the price has been so
volatile and gone up and down everything
to the point where like the meme ended
up capturing the richest man in the
world yeah right so like whatever you
want to say whether it's good or bad or
whatever like if you just look at it
from a structure standpoint it's kind of
like when i always say like aoc and
donald trump right two completely
different views of the world two
completely different sides of the aisle
like they're both incredibly good at
using the internet and getting attention
and uh making people pay attention to
their message
dogecoin i think is a very similar thing
right is that it's it's a strong meme
now does the meme last is it sustainable
all that's up for a question but like it
was a strong enough meme to literally
capture the richest man in the world
yeah
right so i feel like that's a positive
thing uh about it that a lot of people
don't talk about
right i don't know why everyone is all
so caught up like listen i'm like a
pretty rational person i i can identify
things and then still say i own none
someone said antoine on twitter on
youtube said i'm clipping this and
posting on twitter without any context
let's go pomp
[Laughter]
come on